why do you want to be speaker well
partly because it's really a very
difficult and turbulent time i was
really asking myself
what is wrong with me that if it was a a
quiet time
i probably wouldn't have felt the
necessity of putting myself forward but
because it is a troubled time
and because i do care about our
democracy and i do care about parliament
i thought well if you think it's a
really important job to be done
then you should put your hat in the ring
so i'm putting myself forward but i
think there'll be a lot of good
candidates and whoever
gets to be speaker whoever is elected by
the other mps
then i will support them 100 but i'm
putting my hat in the ring and i also
think
you know we've had 600 years of speakers
we've had
75 speakers and
we've only had one woman i think it's
time for another woman because
actually the house of commons has
changed we've now got more than 200
women mps and a woman speaker in the
chair would
send a very good message and show that
parliament has changed and also you know
our parliament is looked to by other
parliaments all around the world
and therefore a speaker who can really
champion parliament is important not
just for
our parliament and our country but it's
important for democracies all around the
world
and there are many women now in
parliaments all around the world
and if they see a woman in the chair of
what is described as the mother of
parliaments which is
how westminster is described it will
give them a tremendous boost
yeah of course we do have deputy female
speakers haven't we in the past um
in fact at the moment i think as well um
what do you think you'll bring to the
role apart from being female
well i think i'll bring an absolute
determination to champion
parliament uh in the country outside of
westminster but also to work with
members of parliament across parties
i've been there
a long time and therefore they all know
me and they know they can trust me and
they know
that i really care about our democracy
and i think it also needs a real firm
hand on the tiller it needs somebody who
is really tough
with a bit of a hind of the rhino
because
um the government really is always
tempted
to push parliament around i've been in
government myself i know how it works
and you really have to have a very
robust speaker in the chair so i think i
will
bring robustness um
as well as being you know relating to
women outside and inside the chamber as
well
and if not you who would you like to see
in the chair
well i think any of the other candidates
they're all very different
but they're all do a very good job in
fact more probably will
declare themselves as the weeks go on so
i think that we always have a very
friendly competition for speaker which
will make a big change from all the
other competitions that are going on
right now
and you know we'll all respect the fact
that the house has a choice
and it depends on what sort of speaker
they want if they want somebody
who's got experience of long years if
they want a woman
if they want well you know they've got a
choice